SPEAKER 1: In Google
Cloud Engineering Support,
our goal is to work smoothly
with you, engineer to engineer,
to resolve any issues you may
encounter when using Google
Cloud Platform products.
This video describes
best practices
for filing an issue report
with our support engineers
in the Google Cloud
Support Center,
but it's applicable to
requesting technical assistance
from any GCP engineer.
This includes support cases,
bug reports, and issue trackers,
and posts to our user groups
and forums, like Stack Overflow.
The key principle is clarity.
Specify the right level
of technical detail
and communicate your
expectations explicitly
so that we can better help
you resolve the issue.
The Support Center's help
page and earlier videos
present the mechanics
of how to file cases.
This will help you understand
what to include in your cases
and why.
We will explain
the details we need
and why they are important.
The four critical details
to include with every case
are specific times when you
experience the issue, the GCP
products you're
using, the location,
and specific identifiers
for any resources
relevant to your case.
Onset time and
duration give us a way
to focus our time
series monitoring
on the relevant period.
Please be explicit about
whether the issue is ongoing
or whether it was only
observable in the past.
If the issue isn't
ongoing, please state that,
and give the end
time if you know it.
ISO 8601 format is a
good choice because it's
unambiguous and easy to sort.
Please always include
the time zone.
Our internal systems tend
to be in Google time, which
is US-specific, but our agents
use a follow the sun model
and may be in
different time zones.
Some issues are
intermittent over a period.
In this case, it's
good to say when
it's first observed or perhaps
note a time in the past
when it was not happening.
Remark about the
frequency of observations
and note one or two
specific examples.
When time is specified
in a relative way,
including omission
of a time zone,
the reader must convert
into an absolute format
that can be input into time
series monitoring tools.
This is error-prone
and costly, especially
considering that each
reader must pay the price.
For example, sending an
email about something
that happened earlier
yesterday causes the reader
to search for a header
in the initial email
and start doing
math in their head.
Phrases to avoid are things
like earlier today, because it's
not specific enough, or
yesterday, because we need
to figure out the
implied date when issues
take multiple days to resolve.
Don't use dates like
9/8 because it's
ambiguous and may be interpreted
differently in other locales.
The Case Creation form includes
basic product selection,
which is used for routing
to a specialist in the area.
This isn't specific
enough to locate
the components or logs that
will help diagnose the issue.
Be as specific as
possible about the product
you're using, ideally
referring to the specific APIs
or console.cloud.google.com
or screenshots.
For APIs, you can link
to the documentation
page, which contains the
product name and the URL.
Tell us about the
mechanism you're
using to initiate the request.
For example, REST API, gcloud
tool, console.cloud.google.com,
or perhaps a tool like
Deployment Manager.
Sometimes multiple
products are involved,
so try to be specific
about each one.
Describe the behavior observing
and what you expected,
then show us what you see.
You should be specific about
the actions you have taken,
as well as the syntax
of any commands you use.
A phrase like "can't
create instance"
doesn't tell us whether
you used gcloud compute,
the developer console UI, or
called it from your own code.
The most clear way to
communicate this example would
be something like "I ran
gcloud compute instances create
my-instance--zone us-central1-a
and got the following error
message."
When including the
location, region and zone
are important to us,
because we often roll out
changes to one region
or zone at a time.
They are a proxy for the
version number of the underlying
software.
We can see if there's a rollout
underway in a given location
or map it to an internal release
ID for use in a bug report.
You should include
something along the lines
of "I tried regions
us-east1 or us-central1."
In your case, please make
sure to always include
specific identifiers.
Project ID is an input to most
of our troubleshooting tools,
and it's a required
field when filing a case.
Please provide a numeric
project ID, not a project name.
If the error is observed
in multiple projects
or in one project,
but not another,
you should include that
information in the description.
Also include IDs of other
objects, like instance
IDs, BigQuery job
IDs, or table names.
IP addresses are another form
of unambiguous identifier.
When specifying a
cloud platform IP,
tell us the context
of how it's used--
for example, if it's
connected to a GCE instance,
a load balancer, a custom route,
or if it's an API endpoint.
If you're troubleshooting
a connection issue,
then tell us a bit
about the IP addresses
that are not part of GCP--
for example, if it's
your home internet,
a VPN end point, or an
external monitoring system.
You should always provide
more specific information
than something like
"one of our instances"
or "we can't connect
from the internet,"
because support
will need to gather
more information from you before
they can begin troubleshooting.
That will mean further delays
in resolving your issue.
For any information
you provide to support,
be specific and explicit.
If relevant, use a screenshot
to show exactly what you see.
For web-based interfaces,
provide a .HAR file or a HTTP
archive.
Our documentation has
instructions on how to get
a .HAR file from
three major browsers.
When troubleshooting networking
issues, attach TCP dump output
if you collect it, and also
attach log snippets and example
stack traces you believe to
be relevant to the issue.
When you file a case, support
uses the priority field
for initial routing, especially
when an issue may page someone.
Case priorities are also
described in the case creation
form itself.
Use P1 for production
emergencies.
Think of case priority in terms
of the impact to your business.
In addition to setting the
priority field correctly,
it's useful to add a
sentence describing
the impact in your words.
For example, you may consider
a problem with the dev version
to be a P1, even if no end users
are directly impacted, if it's
blocking a critical
security fix.
To avoid incorrect
assumptions, it's
helpful to be explicit
about why you selected P1.
Cases have built-in
response timers,
which are designed to set
reasonable expectations most
of the time.
If you have some specific
needs, please let us
know when you need an update.
It's good to say something like,
"I need a response by 5:00 PM,
because that's when
my shift ends."
If you notice you're affected
by an issue that's already
reported on the
status.cloud.google.com,
you can follow the progress
in the dashboard itself
or use the Me Too link in
the cloud support portal
to automatically get
updates for known issues.
When an issue needs to be
handled around the clock,
customers with 24/7
support can request
that the case follow the sun.
Cases that follow the sun will
be reassigned several times
per day, so it's always with
an active support engineer.
A lower priority case will not
be managed around the clock,
as the assigned support
engineer will go off shift
at some point.
This can cause delays if
the assigned engineer is not
in your time zone.
You can ask us to manage
the ticket in your time zone
so you can communicate more
easily with the support
engineer.
For example, you can say
"please manage this case
in my time zone, EST."
This can help if you need a
long discussion with the support
engineer, but may not
help if the development
team is in another time zone.
If you need to continue the
conversation over Google
Hangouts or phone
after filing a case,
please provide a
link or phone number.
If you request it,
support will try
to call when it
does not interfere
with issue resolution.
For video bridges, we strongly
prefer Google Hangouts
but can use anything that
works within a Chrome browser
without requiring extensions.
If you're not requesting
an immediate callback,
please give two or
three time slots
when you're available to get
started with the scheduling.
Thank you for watching.
If you have questions, please
leave them in the comments
section below, and we'll try to
address them in future videos.